the strains of Johannes Brahms Violin
Concerto may sound rather than the
humble city traffic the guest star
Georgian violin virtuoso Lisa but Josh
be playing with the stasi cappella
Berlin led by its chief director Daniel
Barenboim think the Gunderson's people
in Berlin really appreciate music they
pay attention
they'd just come to be able to say they
were here they come here for the
experience it's a marvelous idea
and I hope they keep doing it for many
years my key fact akima that misses me
roughly Anna not if you don't want it
Lisa but Josh Philly is considered one
of the best violinists of her generation
in the world her latest album released
in January also included a performance
of the Brahms Violin Concerto playing
the work together with Daniel Barenboim
was a dream she had since her teens you
know that gives me even resign I always
found his style performing Brahms you
like both the Santana's conductor yeah
so when I got the opportunity to play as
him and I'm not a thought of Brahms
I knew I'd do anything to ensure the
first thing we performed together
it was the Brahms concerto the stage is
just across the street from the Berlin
State Opera House which is currently
undergoing extensive renovations
Birnbaum is also general music director
of the State Opera
the acoustic challenges may open our
venue is far from ideal for classical
music
by the celebrated conductor has been
more than willing to make an exception
these merge to me I don't wanna fall
ideally you do need an indoor space once
a year it's amazing 25
the relaxed free-of-charge event has
been drawing
sighs four years this year an estimated
13,000 attended making this brand day
out of record-breaker
many people don't go to the Opera that
often because it's relatively expensive
so we thought okay let's combine it with
the nice weather we're only in Berlin
temporarily we live in France they're
enjoying the range of arts and cultural
activities here there's really a lot to
see and do despite the unfamiliar
conditions these are bashfully performs
to her usual world class standard you
can't feel a crowd of people with the
sound you have to trust these people to
do their jobs so that it sounds like a
normal concert
and annual extravaganza whose title
really does ring true state opera for
everyone